hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video wie
heute ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
das heutige video entsteht weil ich
spontan also ja ich war gestern
einkaufen und den so größeren
supermärkten gibt es ja meistens auch
diese lotto geschäft kennt ja jeder von
euch wenn man auch post abgeben kann und
so und ich bin dann gestern an seinem
lotto geschäft vorbei gegangen nachdem
ich einkaufen war und da war dann halt
diese rubbellos aktion wo bloß
adventskalender du kannst ja praktisch
da so adventskalender kaufen dafür den
rubbel lose kaufen und die dann
verschenken oder selber öffnen ich weiß
nicht und ich habe die letzten jahre
immer von anderen usern so rubbellos
aktionen gesehen ich habe keinen plan ob
es das war auf jeden fall glaube ich
gibt es das auch schon ein bisschen
länger von natur also das ist jetzt
nicht das erste jahr
ich hatte aber einfach mal für knapp 300
euro lose gekauft sorry ich meine 200
euro an dieser stelle also 100 hier
vielleicht eine kurze einspieler leute
was gilt
ich war gerade einkaufen und ich habe
gesehen bei lotto gibt es wieder so
rubbellos ich habe das noch nie gemacht
es gibt es ja schon eigentlich jedes
jahr oder diese rubbellos aktion ich
weiß nicht ob es immer nur von lotto ist
auf jeden fall dachte ich mir ich muss
aber mitmachen das sind ja so
adventskalender hier und da kann man
halt gruppe lose verkaufen die
rubbellose liegen hier hinten
das sind wirklich jede menge com das
waren auch alle die die noch da hatten
bis auf zehn stück oder so ich weiß es
nicht auf jeden fall gespannt und wir
machen jetzt mal auf vielleicht ziehe
ich aber das gras ist das ist das nicht
so
das team verloren ok so sieht das jetzt
aus ich habe jetzt alle in
adventskalender reihen hat nämlich
umsonst zurückgeben freundlicherweise
und dann schauen wir mal was das hier
heute gibt ihr könnt ihr jetzt schon mal
kommentieren was schätzt ihr wieviel
geld wohne ich da raus dann habe ich
noch diesen wunderschönen nikolaus auch
jetzt sind sie schon rausgefallen oder
was nikolaus adventskalender dazu
bekommen und habe da jetzt einfach mal
alle lose reingesteckt ihr seht schon
das ist pro türchen also die sind jetzt
gerade daraus gefallen so ungefähr 15
dinger 12.15 sachen genau man kann für 1
euro und für 50 cent kaufen und ich
glaube sogar auch für fünf euro ich weiß
es nicht ich habe alle für einen euro
leer gekauft und dann halt den 30 für 50
cent genommen ich bin ultra gespannt ich
habe das noch nie gemacht wir starten
einfach mal hier mit alter das dauert
die aufnahme geht er zwei stunden wenn
ich das jetzt alles hier selber aufrufe
und muss man in rubeln ja eine münze
wäre nicht schlecht oder irgendwie sowas
oder wir nehmen ein messer soll man das
geht bei uns glaube ich besser ich sitz
ja bis morgen hier ach so also sieht das
denn aus wenn man es aufgerüttelt hat
zeige ich euch hier einmal hier steht
jetzt zum beispiel zehn euro 100 euro
noch mal 100 euro
man braucht drei mal den gleichen betrag
um das geld dann wirklich zu gewinnen
dreimal gleiche betrag im rubel fällt
gleich einmal entsprechender geldgewinn
ich habe jetzt hier zweimal 10 euro zwei
mal 100 euro und 2 x 10.000 euro hätte
ich jetzt noch ein drittes mal 10.000
euro hat hätte ich einfach 10.000 euro
geworden also ich habe jetzt hier mal
ordentlich los ihr kriegt ein zeitraffer
und immer wenn was krasses dabei ist
sage ich solch und wie gesagt
kommentiert auf jeden fall macht war
ich kriege dabei schon so ein bisschen
gänsehaut das ist glaube ich nicht gut
mit dem messer
hier haben wir jetzt zwei euro gewonnen
wow das lege ich dann alles so zur seite
ich habe mir mal kurz eine münze nach
links kommen mal die lose die kein
gewinn sind und nach rechts dann die wo
ich halt gewinnen haben wir hier wieder
nichts weitergeht sagt sagt wieder nicht
das sieht wieder schlecht aus und wieder
nichts die sind alle fürn arsch als
entsteht hier eine sauerei war wieder
nichts wieder nichts
hier mal ist mal wieder zwei euro
gewonnen also ich bin jetzt insgesamt
schon bei vier euro wieder nichts wieder
nicht ein euro gewinnen
5 euro und das ist wieder für'n arsch
weiter geht's die nächsten ok wieder ein
euro gewinnen
weiter ist der richtige fitness einheit
heute
und hier haben wir schon wieder ein euro
insgesamt sieben euro es wäre wirklich
super nice wenn ich einmal 100 euro raus
wurde weil das sind dann halt große
schritte die man sich auch hier ist
wieder zwei euro erhoben direkt in den
ersten beiden reihen jeweils 10.000 euro
jetzt brauche ich noch einmal die 10.000
und das ist es nicht
naja immerhin zwei euro ich hätte mir
wirklich mal ein bisschen verstärkung
holen sollen für das video weil so viel
rubbeln kann man ja eigentlich gar nicht
allein die haben wir jeweils wieder ein
euro erhalten zwei euro nähten und das
ist wieder für'n arsch weitergeht kommen
wir machen jetzt hier mit mir weiter das
hier sind jetzt nämlich nur 5000 euro
spitzen gewinnen 5 1 1 war unglaublich
50 cent und nochmal 50 sein
also so sieht das denn aus
ich hatte jetzt wirklich noch nicht
einmal was nicht mal fünf euro und ich
bin ja safe schon 15 minuten hier im
rummel nicht aufgeben weiter geht's so
hier kommt der nächste dicke batzen
wieder ein euro ich habe jetzt schon
zwei mal 100 euro aufgerüttelt zwei mal
10.000 euro jetzt kommen die untersten
beiden gibt mir einfach nur 100 kommen
natürlich wieder nicht altherr müll
ich dachte gerade alltag nein es waren
keine 10.000 euro
die chance ist wahrscheinlich auch ultra
gering dass man hier mal 100 euro
gewinnt glaube ich ihr könnt hier sehen
wir hatten glaube ich dreimal ein euro
und einmal zwei euro also insgesamt auch
hier bei den zehn sängern wieder verlust
gemacht ein euro noch mal einen euro
vielleicht als kleiner zwischenstand ich
hab's safe schon 60 oder 70 lose auf
gerubbelt insgesamt würde ich mal
schätzen mit seinem wert zwischen 50 und
60 euro weil dies meist halt ein euro
lose waren gewonnen habe ich bis jetzt
so circa 20 euro also sagen wir mal
schon schöne vier jahre verlust aktuell
aber sobald ich hier einmal 100 euro auf
rubel sieht die welt natürlich schon
wieder ganz anders aus
wo man schon wieder fünf euro verlust
ich hatte wirklich noch nicht einmal
auch nur fünf euro 1 1 1
nein mein alter ich dachte dass für zehn
euro das ist wirklich nicht waren wie
unwahrscheinlich ist dass hier irgendwas
zu gewinnen alter der hätten doch mal
wenigstens ein bisschen gönnen können
ich habe jetzt wir sind locker schon bei
100 euro verlust also ohne wird also
hier ist auf jeden fall mal wieder gar
nichts bei alter mann fängt wirklich
auch schon so an zu schwitzen ist das
ding so weiter geht es mit dem nächsten
dicken haben das hier sind zwar alles
ein euro lose okay hier muss jetzt was
bei sein 1 euro 10 euro
komm bitte ja und nein
ob man diese ganzen neuen verleihen aber
auch ne ich dachte gerade jetzt habe ich
100 euro gewonnen wirklich all das ist
richtig für das gehirn so verwirrend
diese ganzen nullen und die eurozeichen
sind dann auf den ersten blick wenn man
die nur so halb auf rubbelt auch aus wie
ne 0 und der verlust wird immer immer
größer ein euro gewinnen haben wir
wieder ein euro gewinnen wir haben war
wieder ein euro gewinn alter wieder ein
euro gewinnen werde er eine eure
gewinnen bringt mir halt absolut gar
nicht ob man also das waren jetzt halt
wieder 15 euro 4 euro gewonnen 11 euro
verloren
danke leute ich will schon eigentlich
gar nichts mehr sagen ich will einfach
weiter und wenn mal fünf euro dabei sind
melde ich mich wieder
[Musik]
oh mann
man hat einmal ganz kurz so einmal
bleibt das herz stehen weil da so viele
nullen sind und dann wird einem klar
okay es sind nur zwei mal 100 euro und 2
x 10.000 euro und haben 18 eur 500.000
euro 10 euro 5 euro
eine mutter hunderttausend 10.000 euro
ein euro 1 euro
das kann wirklich nicht sein 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 12 1 euro dinge haben wir
hier und nicht mal ein euro gewinnen
vielleicht liegt es ja auch an der
filialen durch war dass sie da wirklich
nur mittellose haben aber das ohne
scheiß das ist ja auch wirklich so ein
krasser unterschied zwischen dem was ich
eingesetzt haben und zwischen dem was
ich da gerade heraus und wieder nix hier
komplett wieder alles finden wir legen
hier den endspurt ein
komm jetzt aber mal hier ein euro und
wieder nichts mehr ich glaube es wird
nichts mehr
50 cent müll ich werde irgendwie schon
ganz benommen von diesem zeug was hier
über herumfliegt das hier sind jetzt auf
jeden fall die letzten die noch anfallen
ja das war es dann auch schon mit dem
nikolaus ach leute was soll ich sagen
die kamera hat irgendwie 45 minuten
ihren geist aufgegeben deswegen waren
die letzten jetzt nicht mehr drauf aber
ist auch ganz egal wie zählt jetzt mal
was am ende über geblieben ist wie viel
ich gewonnen habe ich denke es sind
täglich mehr als 30 oder 40 euro ich
habe knapp 200 euro eingesetzt deswegen
ist das glaube ich echt nicht viel also
hat euch von pech kann man sagen ein
euro zwei euro drei euro
350 euro 50 fünf euro 50 6 euro 50 7
euro 8 euro
9 euro 10 euro
11 euro 13 04 10 euro 15 euro
17 eur 18 euro auf 19 eur 20 eur 1 20
eur auf 23 eur auf 50 eur 50 5 20 auf 50
7 20 eur 39 eur 31 euro
51 50 euro 50 530 euro hier haben wir
dann nochmal 35 euro 50 36 eur 38 euro
und 39 euro alter wer hätte es gedacht
das ist so weckwerth ich nicht also ich
habe wirklich damit gerechnet dass ich
schon wahrscheinlich so 100 euro safe
wieder raus kriege aber so sollte es
halt ich sein deswegen meine meinung ist
lass die finger besser davon ihr könnt
ihr geld verlieren aber vielleicht kann
man auch glück haben ich weiss es nicht
ist sowieso erst ab 18 aber ist ja auch
egal ich hoffe ihr hattet trotzdem
bisschen spaß beim anschauen konnte mir
beim leiden zuschauer und für mich war
es zwischendurch wirklich sehr
deprimierend wenn da halt nur 50 cent
oder 1 euro die ganze zeit steht wir
sehen uns dann übermorgen wieder da
kommt endlich das video mit den zehn
laptops aus polen abonniert super gern
den kanal es wird sich lohnen ich zeige
euch immer kurs die ecke wir haben ganz
ganz viele sachen saugroboter des
iphones habe ich schon zwei und noch
vieles mehr
das wird alles im dezember verlost im
dezember gibt es ganz viele videos danke
fürs zuschauen
haut rein abonnieren lohnt sich